whoa all right hello everybody this is
the first video I've ever done it was
rough crude the commentary was stiff and
I was nervous I also only had an
audience of one only my best friend was
a subscriber but it didn't matter
because I enjoyed it I wanted to do more
I never really expected to go anywhere
with it you know I looked up to the big
youtubers so I made a compilation and
somehow that video drew attention and
suddenly I had a few hundred subscribers
and that was a huge number to me
incredible really so I kept at it yeah
all right ex came penumbra nightmare
house cry of fear on the custom stories
god I love the end user custom stories
just being able to entertain you guys
day by day's greatest feeling in the
world and then it just kind of
snowballed from there I couldn't tell
you exactly when it started growing
exponentially but it did
slender came along SCP my reaction
compilations were a big hit I kept at it
and you guys kept at it you all of you
are the reason why I'm enjoying any
success today and I never ever want to
forget that or where I came from this
has all happened so fast but it doesn't
matter because I'm not gonna change not
a day has gone by that I haven't thought
about how far I've come
so thank you it's been a crazy ride to
get here so quickly and I don't even
know how it happened but I know that you
did it because you guys was sharing my
videos every single day and just
enjoying commenting and liking it's it's
been incredible you've changed my life
in more ways than you know so thank you
all and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye